[Music]
Shazaam hey everybody its Charlie this
is gonna be my Suzanne video I also have
details on the comic-con trailer what's
going on with Black Adam in just the DC
panel at comic-con in general there's a
bunch of trailers are gonna be dropping
so if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there's a new round of that flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video biggest thing
first a lot of people were confused this
morning about who was standing next to
Shazam how can he coexist with Shazam at
the same time so this is actually Billy
Batson in full Shazam form standing next
to Freddy Freeman who's one of his
foster brothers they're doing the Geoff
Johns new 52 Shazam run meaning that all
the family members will get powers so
Mary Marvel Freddy Freeman
everybody he's got a whole perception
about the magical world he can see the
magical world that we can and he's also
super strong he can cast spells there's
no instruction book though so he has no
idea how to cast a spell really he kind
of tests it on some things you can say
to Emma Stephen get a lot of money but
he can't shut it off so as you can see
like most of the focuses on the costume
itself now this is a screen grab from
the movie most of you have spotted that
they've tuned it up quite a bit in
post-production like there's lightning
highlights on the gauntlets they've
turned the sandals into actual sandals
so they don't look like metal boots
anymore
they've lit up the lightning bolt and
there's a lightning bolt that's lit up
on his belt buckle too so everything
glows just a little bit but the other
big thing too is as they've used cg to
slim him down just a little bit so this
is what zachary levi looked like when
they were actually filming it behind the
scenes he got bolt up big time like Ben
Affleck in just like the chunkier
version of the Ben Affleck Batman
costume they put some padding beneath it
too then in post-production slimmed his
waist down a little bit if you didn't
watch it either behind the scenes on
Batman V Superman or Justice League Ben
Affleck did get pretty jacked but they
still add a lot of padding on top of
that so that it gives it that comic-book
look the characters are superheroes so
their physiques are meant to defy
physics like they're meant to have these
crazy awesome bodies
you ready for another take but otherwise
he's flushing about the place and the
material in the suit starts to stretch a
little bit but during a fight sequence
where for the person you're fighting
because of the nature of that costume so
of course everybody even gal gadot gets
tuned just a little bit so that
everything looks perfect so I'm guessing
except when he's calling down extra
power this is about as big as he's gonna
look through most of the movie we also
found out who's gonna be playing the
wizard Shazam it's gonna be Djimon
Honsou from the Marvel movies
Korath himself is gonna be starring in
two Captain Marvel movies one at the
beginning of the year from marvel the
other from DC at the end of the year
star-lord the plot synopsis doesn't
reference Black Adam but it just says in
the film Billy is assigned to a new
foster home where he befriends comic
book super fan Freddy
so Freddy is the interest to the comic
book world he's probably the Superman
super fan one day
Billy's subway ride is interrupted by a
mysterious wizard play by Djimon Honsou
who has been searching for ages to find
the right successor to inherit his
powers he reveals the teen has been
selected to gain an assortment of
abilities and all it takes is for Billy
to say Shazam
so he says teen I'm guessing that means
he's like 13 14 during the course of the
movie still very young but not a really
little kid and not quite in high school
just a reminder if you didn't see the
earlier Shazam videos that I did they
already did a couple promo videos so
I'll link one of those at the end of
this hey everybody exactly and one part
of our set we can't really show you all
of set because I would spoil everything
it wouldn't be fun like explain this
movie in one sentence a sure it's a fun
family movie and it's everyone's gonna
want to watch it yes do you agree I
agree I in one sense I would say this
movie is like Superman meets big so for
most of you you don't know who Superman
is and if you're old enough and cool
enough you know the Tom Hanks movie big
that's kind of what what that is right
you know you know I love Superman I grew
up watching Superman as a kid and I
think but they call it a mixture of Tom
Hanks big in a Superman movie so if
you're not to be comic-book
reader the Shazam character shares a lot
of the same tone as the Superman
character so creatively they flow from a
lot of the same energy they even look
very similar there are a lot of jokes
about that in the comics in the past but
for the most part I think that Henry
Cavill is only involved with this on a
cameo level because Freddie Freeman was
seen walking around on set with the Man
of Steel logo on his shirt that pretty
much confirms this picks up after the
events of Justice League so Superman has
been doing his Superman thing he's been
inspiring little kids these foster
children Billy Batson and his friends
are inspired by him so they want to be
superheroes too so I'll be curious to
see what they referenced during the
movie without actually having Henry
Cavill on screen you may have seen Henry
Cavill himself is doing the press tour
for Mission Impossible 6 but he also
started doing his Superman workouts
again so people are like does this mean
that he's getting ready to announce a
Man of Steel sequel I've already done a
video about the actual things that he
said about the next Man of Steel movie
they do want to do it they have a story
in mind there are a couple people that
do want to direct it but Warner Brothers
hasn't announced anyone yet so what I
actually think that he's getting ready
for is to shoot a Shazam cameo I just
think they haven't done that yet they'll
wait till like the last possible minute
then they'll tack it on it'll either be
a post-credits scene or he'll show up at
the very end of the film to talk to
Billy because if you're gonna have an
entire family of super-powered
individuals foster children in real life
the Superman is probably gonna want to
keep tabs on them and technically this
is still a shared DC movie universe so
these movies are meant to connect
meaning that it's still Henry Capitals
Superman that's keeping an eye on them
so a lot of the actors and the producers
have been making jokes about Superman
just teasing that he's going to show up
somewhere but like I said I think it's
only supposed to be a very brief cameo
the other big thing speaking of cameo
the rock confirmed that he's not going
to appear as Black Adam during the
Shazam movie they're gonna shoot the
black out a movie at the end of next
year so if he does appear during this
movie at all it might be in a very brief
post-credit scene reference just as a
way to link this to that film because
eventually they will have to face each
other but it seems like they're saving
that for a sequel because they don't
want the tone of the Shazam movie to get
too heavy thing that right with Wonder
Woman and Aquaman we have some few
surprises down the line so we decided to
do is
to create a scenario where black Adam is
having his standalone movie right
Captain Marvel
Shazam will have his standalone movie
and then that way we're building our
world up that way and then we can come
together at some other point so we have
we have a surprise for Black Adam coming
up I can't into rock as Black Adam is
probably about as serious as you can get
inside the DC Universe he will put the
hurt on anybody that shows up in his
film but the rock did tease a bunch of
DC Universe characters showing up during
his Black Adam movie but he didn't say
who I think Superman is also a pretty
good likelihood like they might cameo
Superman in the Black Adam movie in lieu
of doing another Man of Steel movie
right away so just keep that in the back
of your mind but reminder about the
comic-con panel they're showing off a
full Aquaman trailer with finished CG a
teaser for Shazam they confirmed that
there would be a teaser of some sort I
hope they released that online it sounds
like they will and then a Wonder Woman
too behind the scenes teaser because
they're still shooting that movie so
whatever footage they drop I will
totally do videos for no worries leave
all your requests in the comments below
and I'll name a new giveaway winner when
I post new DC so we'll be ramping up for
Comic Con next week I'll start posting
videos about what my schedule is gonna
be in the trailers that we found out
about and all the other really cool
stuff that's going on but while you wait
for everything click here for that
Shazam teaser and click here to learn
all about Nick Fury showing up during
spider-man far from home thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]